Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a lot of time
on this because I don't have a lot of time to
spend on this. But Marjorie Taylor Greene must
be removed from the House of Representatives.
She appeared on Sebastian Gorka program yesterday.
This was one of Trump's many various advisers,
and she suggested using Second Amendment rights
against Democrats. She actually says in this
segment, the reason we have the Second Amendment
is so that we can use it against people who are
doing the things Democrats are doing
right now. She should be removed
from from the House. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: They're coming for our guns and
for our civil rights. Are they not?
Speaker 1: They're not. But OK.
Speaker 7: Oh, of course they are.
As a matter of fact, Stacey Abrams,
who is running for governor for the second time
in Georgia, and her announcement speech after she
said that she would pursue aggressive vaccination
of Georgians. She, the next time she talked about
was grabbing people's guns. She hates Georgia's
Second Amendment rights. She she wants to stop
constitutional carry, which is exactly
what our state legislators and our governor
should be pursuing right now. They
should be passing it and it into law.
But yeah, no Democrat. They hate our Second
Amendment because ultimately the truth is it's our
Second Amendment rights, our right to bear arms
that protect Americans and give us the ability
to defend ourselves from a tyrannical government.
Speaker 1: Now remember, there are no prominent
Democrats suggesting getting
rid of the Second Amendment,
and there is no serious legal opinion that some
regulations around firearms violate the Second
Amendment. These are widely established principles
of law at this point, but doesn't matter to her,
Speaker 7: and I hate to use this language. But
Democrats, they're exactly they're doing exactly
what our founders talked about when they
gave us these precious rights that we have.
And, you know, no one wants violence. And I say
it all the time. I'm not a violent person. I
hope to never see a civil war in this
country. And that's why you hear me
tossed around national divorce because the federal
government has grown so big and the Democrats are
willing to use the power of the federal government
that that it really violates people's rights. And
this is why state rights are so important. And
it's a shame that we shouldn't think that way.
But you know, I don't know what's going to happen
in the future, but we always have to make sure
that we're defending our Second Amendment rights.
Speaker 1: So the key line there is Democrats are
doing the things for which the founders gave
us the Second Amendment to protect us against.
She's saying Democrats are doing things worthy of
so-called Second Amendment solutions. She should
be removed from Congress immediately. It's like a
do not. Pasco do not collect $200. Just get out.
Unfortunately, expulsion from Congress requires
a resolution to expel in the ethics committee
an investigation over the alleged
actions and then a two thirds vote.
Democrats will never get a two thirds vote to
expel Marjorie Taylor Greene in the House unless
she quite literally was charged with a felony
because most Republicans think this is fine.
And you know what? She's going to get reelected.
That's the scariest part. You know, Jewish space
lasers, starting forest fires. At this point, it
really shouldn't shock us. But despite all of it,
she's going to get reelected. Isn't the
Secret Service obligated to investigate her
at this point? And these people with the violence
and the guns and they still get into power? And
obviously we have to say this says something about
them that they keep electing people with these,
these sort of violent fantasies, Madison Cawthorn
and others talking about using Second Amendment
solutions against Democrats. And I guess it's sort
of like they love violence. They just don't want
the people on their side to be subjected to
it. But they don't really have a problem with
violence, and it is without a doubt a form of
stochastic terrorism. This woman is disgusting.